[Music]
it's something that I'm sure many of you
will have seen before flanked by metal
heavy generals and Veterans of conflicts
past Vladimir Putin sits impassively in
moscow's Red Square as the annual
Victory Day Parade unfolds in front of
him
[Music]
commemorating the Soviet Union's Triumph
in World War II were Nazi Germany it
also serves as a very public display of
Russia's current military night
for all that the rhetoric was as
belligerent as usual perhaps even more
so in fact the parade itself has been
significantly smaller the Russians will
they cite security concerns is the
reason a little less than a week ago a
drone attack struck the Kremlin there
was footage released pretty soon after
which showed a device detonating or
perhaps being blown up above the walls
of the Fortified Russian complex
the Russians say it was a Ukrainian
attempt to assassinate
foreign
says it was most likely a false flag and
denies its involvement
at the time of recording the war that
Russia assumed it would win in a handful
of days has been going for 440 of them
so just how much power is Vladimir Putin
actually projecting I'm Neil Patterson
and this is this guy Museum
well I am in the studio with our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wycon and our military analyst Professor
Michael Clark gents good to see you both
um and I suppose we really need to start
with a reminder of exactly what this day
commemorates Dominic
so this is Victory Day it is the day
when Russians remember the victory in
what they call the Great Patriotic War
the second world war as we call it when
the Russians a huge costs and huge
sacrifice did eventually defeat the
Nazis and expel them from Russia and for
Vladimir Putin it's a day where you
emphasize the fact that the Russians not
just fought Germany back in the 40s but
also in his mind is fighting the West
now and that's in line with what Russian
propaganda has been doing as well which
is kind of conflating the war now with
the war back then you may wonder how
that happens and and the argument made
by his regime is that effectively
Britain and America and the West was
kind of in League with the Nazis and
therefore just as Russia fought Napoleon
in the 19th century and uh has fought
the West conflating Germany and Britain
and America in the 40s it is fighting
the West again so effectively Putin's
kind of hijacked what was very much a
day all about celebrating the victory
against Germany alone I mean Michael I
think the Brits used to send along
representatives to to Victory and we
fought alongside them absolutely yeah so
I mean we celebrated that as allies in
Britain and America France Poland and
would have representatives there
sometimes very high level
representatives in order to emphasize
the fact that we were Partners Putin
became prime minister in 1999. so he's
already been in power for 24 years and
as his power has gone on these Victory
Day celebrations have become more
important to him because he takes pride
in in Russia's military prowess he wants
to say to the Russian people we've
always got cash and the Russian economy
will always be strong because we're an
energy economy and we've got our
military and as his policies have become
more aggressive over the years in
international Affairs so his military
demonstrations become more important to
him yeah I wonder though I mean how
strong a message is he sending to the
Russian people at a time when you know
but my early educated estimation this
was a scaled down Victory Parade by any
measure it was scaled down Russians
ordinary muscovites couldn't actually
get to see it which is astonishing
because it's a very long Parade route
they spent all day I think trying to get
to see it and muscovites were saying to
them how do we get to see this parade
which is a big change from the past it
was canceled in 22 cities and the
immortal regiment parade was canceled as
well across across Russia that that is
when Russians come out on the streets
with big photos they hold up of the
their loved ones their relatives their
ancestors who died in the Second World
War I think the fear for the government
was they might have been coming out on
mass with photographs of photographs of
Russian military personnel that had been
lost wouldn't they almost certainly and
what this government's been very
successful at and gone to Great Lengths
to do is to try and mask the extent of
casualties in a country as vast as
Russia you can do that because the body
bags are going home to quite often sort
of villages sparsely sort of not that
close to each other in the East and not
as many from those Metropolitan centers
like Saint Petersburg among so yeah I
think a lot of photographs of Russian
soldiers who've died in this War I think
would have would have been alarming to
Russians and certainly not want what the
government wanted would have wanted to
see we were settling in this morning for
a two-hour event and we all got
ourselves settled in the studio thinking
okay well this will be eight till ten
you've got your coffee you've got your
biscuits absolutely we've been to the
gents first and all that we've done all
the right all the right things that
professional broadcasters should do and
it was all over in 45 minutes I mean my
coffee was still warm and it was the
marches the speech by Putin which is
pretty short and then a little bit of
military hardware and that first of all
was the Heritage stuff the t-34 tank
leading at the iconic tank of the second
world war was the only tank I think I
saw it was the only one is that I saw
and then there was some armored
personnel Vehicles again Heritage
Vehicles more than anything else then
the nucleus some nuclear stuff the the
big InterContinental missiles I think it
was probably the summit missile the big
uh the Satan missiles that as they call
it the biggest one that Putin keeps
boasting about there's a few of those
and that was it we were waiting for you
know the armored vehicles the tanks all
the new material all the high-tech stuff
that normally goes past nothing and in
45 minutes it was all over is this
because all of that kit and equipment is
being used elsewhere no obviously I mean
they can always pull equipment together
that's the point um you know you need
half a dozen of them or 10 or 15 of them
I mean it's not a parade of hundreds and
hundreds of Tanks but it's a braid with
different types of things and those of
us who who take an interest in these
Affairs are always looking for what's
the new stuff what we might normally
have expected these you know the most
modern tanks but there was nothing and I
think the the reasons for that is not
because they don't have them but because
I think Putin didn't want to emphasize
that side of it and I think they just
wanted this parade and the whole event
to be over quite quickly to reduce the
hostages the fortune of something going
wrong or some incident happening or
something that would undermine the whole
message of the day that would be my own
estimate well that has to be said they
do have a lot less tanks don't they a
lot fewer and actually I was there a
year ago and there was a there are a lot
fewer tanks there because they had
already lost a lot since then they've
lost how many times what 1500 1500 yeah
at least uh that you know that our
certified certifiably lost by visual
identification and actually it's
climbing now towards over two thousand
of course we we also heard from from
Vladimir Putin himself and and speaking
not that far of course from from where
the Russians claim Ukraine launched a
drone strike against the very heart of
the Russian kind of political apparatus
I mean listening to Putin himself what
did we learn there was an awful lot of
quite quite concerning rhetoric being
used there was it was it was sort of
classic Putin but very short not like
the speech you gave in February when he
basically told the Russians that this
war is something that they were going to
have to get used to kind of normalizing
a war it would be going on in the
background for his sort of hints that
for years to come this is more of a
short rant about the West about the
globalist elites he says that have taken
over and hijacked the West responsible
for the russophobia that's persecuting
Russia a West that is destroying Family
Value so a little bits about that but
he's painting a picture of the West
being mad bad and and dangerous to
Russia says that it's uh propagating a
system of violence and robbing others
and using terrorism but the heart of the
speech or the most Punchy and frankly
the the Madder Sandy bits when he said
the West is trying to cancel the outcome
of the second world war so at an event
where as we're saying you know
traditionally we have seen uh Western
leaders John Major went to the Victory
Day Parade in 1995. we now have the
Russian leader saying that the West is
trying to cancel the outcome of the
second world war and that's basically
explained by this this idea as we're
saying that that Putin is peddling which
is that Russia is now alone standing up
that the heir to the values and the
world ordered the second world war
fought for and that so many Russian
soldiers died protecting Russia alone is
standing up against this mad bad West
that is a threat to that it sounds
insane but within the frame of reference
that he's been propagating and his
propaganda as well it makes sense to him
and he May well believe it himself
Michael yes it's I mean Russia is a
revisionist power so is China I mean
there are four big powers in the world
that make the political weather for
everybody else America China Russia and
India and two of those four China and
Russia are explicitly revisionist which
is to say that they're trying to change
the rules of world politics that they're
actually trying to uh remake the rules
of world politics now we haven't seen
revisionist Powers in the world since
the Axis powers of the 1930s the fascist
Powers were revisionist because they
wanted to change the rules that had
emerged at the end of the first world
war and that's exactly the message as
Dominic says
um of Russia now they're saying that
first of all that the second world war
was not the way the rest of the world
sees it the second world war was Russia
standing up to the fascists who were
somehow driven created by the west and
increasingly he sees himself performing
this role of of writing the wrongs of
history in a way that will put him on
the same scale as Peter the Great
Catherine the Great Joseph Stalin and
Vladimir Putin
[Music]
that is not famed for its tolerance of
dissent there has been much more than
you might expect presenters on Russian
State tv well they've been critical of
the strategy in Ukraine Evgeni pregosian
the head of the paramilitary Wagner
Group which has been providing Russia
with much of its calendar well he's been
pointedly accusing decision makers of
treason for not providing his men with
sufficient ammunition
oh well let's return to our
International Affairs editor Dominic
Wilcon and security and defense analyst
Professor Michael Clarke Dom I mean you
have to wonder just how effective the
projection of power of the Victory Day
Parade was given such levels of descent
yeah you have what I think probably
Putin sees that as kind of that that is
acceptable in the sense of the in the
court of the of the modern days are that
he is to a certain extent as long as
he's done he he seems to feel
comfortably in control but what's clever
about Putin is that you know for all his
faults he he understands the Russian
psyche he understands he's tapping into
a deep um well of paranoia that Russians
have always had for geographical reasons
that very exposed western border that
Napoleon the Nazis is a trampled and
violated and for historical geographical
reasons that they have this paranoia but
there's a reason why Putin has banged on
about uh the the victory over the Nazis
uh throughout his time in office and why
this day is certain important to him and
arguably arguably that's because Russia
is such a vast diverse country there's
not much that holds it together apart
from that memory of that great Victory
because every almost every Russian
family will have a relative that whose
photo they can hold whose memory of
whose sacrifice they are proud of yeah
of collections of medals on display at
the victory day period on some of the
older attendees there's clearly a long
and proud yeah tradition of a military
tradition in this country right and
Russia is huge it doesn't have any isms
to believe in anymore it doesn't have
any strong leaders Putin would like to
be seen as a strong leader but he's not
a Stalin or a Lennon it doesn't have a
rule of law it doesn't have a system of
government really it's run by a
basically a collapse of kleptocratic
cabal and so the one thing I think that
I think this is this is a persuasive
argument that ties Russians together is
that memory of the victory over the
Nazis which is why Putin has made a lot
of his claim that Ukraine is run by
Nazis when it obviously isn't it's run
by a Jewish man whose family were wiped
out along with six million Jews and 27
odd million Soviets by the Nazi
government but but that hasn't stopped
Putin making this claim that nuts that
Ukraine is run by Nazis and I think it's
for these this deep sort of historical
reason that that does chime with many
Russians and I think that the hope is
that with this parade he's tapping into
that every year but it with every year
it's looking looking weaker and if this
is a sequel to The Great Patriotic War
when he's celebrating a victory the
question obviously the minds of Russians
is when is Victory coming in this sequel
clearly not anytime soon the prevailing
ISM in Russia is cynicism that's it
that's theism pessimism or cynicism
that's theism and remember I mean as
Dominic says I mean Russia is an
internal Empire
it is the Russian Federation itself is
an Empire and the point about Empires is
that they're either Contracting or
expanding and one of the things that
really bothers the Russians deep down in
the psyche is that the Russian Empire
itself the Federation of Russia May
collapse and I want to attend to that to
that drone strike that took place are we
any closer to understanding the truth of
what happened there I mean ukrainians
are claiming it to be a false flag well
it's created a huge amount of conspiracy
theories and a whole Welter of different
different stories and claims and counter
claims I think you know if it was the
Russians doing it as a false flag
operation the argument goes that to
continue enslaving the uh the Russian
people Herman gerings of the Nuremberg
to enslaver people you just need to
scare them to keep this going Russians
the Russian government needs to keep
coming up with new ways of scaring
Russian people and whoever did it knew
exactly what they were doing this drone
flew over some Basil's Cathedral Red
Square the lead in Mausoleum the walls
of the Kremlin and into the Kremlin
itself so about four or five icons there
and on the one hand it projects an image
of weakness but I think if you're
watching at home if you're Russian it
makes you worried it makes you feel
alarmed and if you need an excuse to
cancel 22 Victory Day parades around the
country and to ban The Immortal regiment
parades then that's one way of doing it
on the other hand there are no no
shortage of security threats and reasons
to be worried about security attacks on
our refineries in the rest of across
Russia I think you can argue either way
if it was ukrainians it was an
extraordinary feat to pull off because
that is a very protective building and I
think if Ukraine was behind this
officially in some way of key have
planned this I think it was
extraordinarily stupid of them because
there was not nothing to gain materially
from this an enormous amount to lose
because you know if Ukraine looks as if
it's launching strategically effective
attacks on Russia itself then it will
lose Western support and then it loses
the war simple as that and one of the
counter-offensive the Ukrainian
counter-offensive that we have been told
has been coming for quite some time
doing aware doing or when doing what
it's going to look certainly not and no
sugar no sugary there's I mean what we
do know is that they've created what
looked like 12 new brigades of about say
60 000 new troops which is not that many
um and that they've got
um at least three probably quite heavily
armored brigades amongst that and then
they've got another four or six veteran
brigades to which they've given some of
the new equipment but I mean any
military professional will tell you
looking at Foster space ratios as they
say that gives you a front that you
could you could cut through anything on
a front of maybe 40 or 50 kilometers at
most but that's across the front of
almost a thousand kilometers so of a
thousand kilometers fighting front which
50 kilometers are you going to cut
through and to do what and as some
people say I mean some of the ukrainians
are incredibly confident about this and
they're very upbeat the Russians will
throw more people at it they'll throw
more troops more equipment at it and
it'll just clothes around you but bottom
line for me is if the ukrainians can
threaten Crimea not take Crimea if they
can threaten Crimea credibly then
they'll come out of this ahead in terms
of of pushing the Russians towards some
sort of more meaningful ceasefire and
the worry sorry the worry in the west I
think is if they do threaten Crimea then
that does does that then threaten Putin
enough to do something extreme that's
certainly a preoccupation that that's
been bothering people like Emmanuel
macron an arguments to be made I think
in Washington as well and that's one
reason why the the West hasn't given I
think Ukraine is as full of support
militarily as they as they might have
but I think you know I think as this war
drags on I think there's a greater
enthusiasm all that resistance is ebbing
away do you think Mike
yes I mean the danger is that unless the
ukrainians are seen to be decisive
unless they can change the the balance
on the battlefield and so not just do
well but be seem to be decisive so that
it looks as if they could throw the
Russians out Say by this time next year
or 18 months at the most if they create
that expectation in the west then the
West will stick with it well that isn't
isn't that the point and it's a question
that the three of us have returned to
countless times over the past 12 months
is what does Victory look like to
Ukraine actually I think Victory to
Ukraine and to the West would be
throwing the Russians out of the
territory as they've taken since
February 22. if you could do that you
could say right we've reversed the The
Invasion we reverse this imperialist
adventure any more than that's a bonus
um and the ukrainians will say well
we're going for everything they've got
to say that but in reality this is like
turning back Saddam Hussein in 1991 he
invaded Kuwait the the world united
through him out of Kuwait and said right
that's it we've reversed the decision
and what happens to Saddam now is not
our problem if we could reverse this
Invasion so that Putin has failed he's
paid a heavy price for it what now
happens in Russia is their problem not
ours that would look like success to me
and I think to a lot of politicians in
the west but if you talk to ukrainians
victory for them is the Russians being
thrown out of all territory so Crimea as
well and the question is will they
settle for a compromise and I think the
ukrainians you talk to when you go there
ultimately what they want is for this
never to happen again so if Russia has
to be beaten resoundingly and decisively
so they never have a base from which to
launch this kind of operation again so
effectively for most ukrainians that
does mean retaking Crimea although you
you if I think they can be reassured
that it will never happen again then
they may settle for the Russians hanging
on to Crimea okay so here is the
dangerous status quo which we might
contemplate the ukrainians throw the
Russians out of everything they've taken
since 22 they want to go further but we
say no no you're not going further we'll
put the donbass the the the the two
Breakaway republics and Crimea into an
international negotiation which will run
for 30 years come up with nothing
doesn't matter it takes it off the off
the table for a while and meanwhile you
will come into NATO with these new two
boundaries and the Russians won't dare
threaten these new NATO boundaries now
that would on paperwork but my goodness
that would be dangerous that would be
high stakes NATO politics I think the
only thing that is certain is that we
three will meet again soon and discuss
these topics
good to see you thank you
my thanks to Dominic wycon Michael
Clarke and of course to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Neil Patterson this Edition was produced
by soiler Apparition our editor is
Phillip
[Music]